all right listen up bub I want to make
one thing very clear to you hello
everybody welcome back to surfing
simulator as it turns out the kidney
operation was not much different than PC
and I blew through it on the first try
in two minutes so I decided to move on
to the lovely eyeball operation here
with my lovely friend Bobby Bob hey hey
come on wake up buddy
time for another operation ru yo y'all
right there y'all right there
yeah eyeballing me ha ha ha shut up ok
so I need to first figure out how to get
the goggles off of him because how am I
supposed to be able to do this surgery
if I can't get the goggles off so I'm
guessing I need to break them think not
sure hey what you having a bad dream
there buddy well you're about to have a
bad life so gotta get the ok that's not
normal it's not normal oh boy
ok something has gone horribly wrong
again like usual and there we go got it
off kind of can you get the rest of that
off please why are you bleeding so hard
you only had a hammer in your skull yep
they're almost almost got it almost
there we go
Oh your heart rate seems to be done no
you're eyeballing me whoo-hoo good god
he's still looking at me I don't think
you like the way that I treated him does
that feel good Bob there we go
ok I think I got one actually no no this
might actually work ha ha I might
actually be doing something correctly
turn your head Bob don't look at the
knife don't look at it huh hey there we
go I got it now I just have to dig your
eyes out it's gonna work does it feel
okay
God you EEP burn Briana
Lauren boy hombre oh no they're not
working brown brown brown you know oh my
goodness aah
get out get out get out well don't get
out but oh my that is not right oh good
golly so what do I do about that how do
i how do I get that out Oh
oh I don't want to be a doctor anymore
but doctor you the best oh shut up nurse
maybe I'm not actually a real doctor
good God can't fit two in one no it
doesn't want to cooperate it just wants
to dance that's all they wanted to do
maybe that's all I've all got this in
the other Oh God oh ha ha you feeling ok
there Bob how you doing Bob we Oh God
Oh Oh doh he's flatlining clear good
door closed it yeah job nurse nurse
doctor what the hell happened to you oh
man oh man oh man oh man hope do do do
do do do you do you
Budi Budi Budi over you you boob oh I
did the patient died again please
I said corpse here we go
whoa that was a close one
boop-boop-boop-boop maybe to you buddy I
think I need something that won't Claus
cause blunt force trauma to the face
which is exact locations when towei then
well how am I supposed to do this God
dang it it just pulls right out of the
eye
oh I just do what achievement was that
almost
who's got it you're almost there you're
yeah I did it
oh ah not that one not that one
oh yeah whatever though that one is off
oh you pretty pretty princess you look
at you go go God and you're dead I got a
pull out ha ha ha ok always got it Oh
got it but that hurt a little bit
bad pulled down why in the world would
you ever be worried about little ol me
with whatever the hell device this is oh
I got it
yay kinda Brett Ritz all I need to do
now is just scoop your eye to the point
where it's scoopable okay I made a
grievous ear oh god that is horrifying
rip come on get in that give in the eye
oh the eye is curly Oh Oh roof there we
go good as new
the eye is currently occupied by that
other girl oh he's gonna die hi someone
put on some death metal music here I
mean you're bleeding a bit but hey it
feels so good
why gonna be okay God Wow feels oh good
oh babe baby deep ruby deep baby a baby
get high abigai boo boo you boo boo yeah
boo boo boop boop need a better angle
OOP bibbidi there we go I'll go with
what you judge was a good idea doctor
are you sure you should be playing with
a basin like that shut up nurse I don't
even know if you're a real nurse which
would be kind of fitting cuz I don't
know if I'm a real doctor
hey stop moving stop moving stop moving
there we go there's no way I can be
delicate if you keep moving like that ah
yeah now I want the eight ball he's out
of here the eight ball in that socket
but elavil this one is in there whoa
God that was the first really truly fun
surgeon simulator level I've ever done
it wasn't it wasn't like super
aggravating cuz it wasn't meant to be it
was just meant to be horrible and awful
but either way I liked it a lot so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching there's gotta be more certain
simulator to come with the tooth
and the something else transplant I have
no idea but anyway thank you again and
as always I will see you in the next
video